auf servern ist nämlich immer so ich bin
nach baldigen sachen hey leute und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge hunger games sieht man mit
prominenten gast gast gast gast von von
bewertest du ich bin alles geht los alle
laufen los was da los war
er läuft nicht mehr los ich werde ihn
festgehalten oder sowas machen witze
lauf doch es geht so nicht neu aufbauen
so in chengdu ein sportinternat leo
fischer ich sehe dich komm mit denen
hier war mit auf ich habe also gar
nichts
ja egal ich hab auch fast gar nichts
kommen jetzt kommt total.com erst mal
mit diesem ich bin jetzt kann ich gehen
nächste mich wo da du guckst du zu mir
hin letztlich kann nicht laufen
der läuft deshalb bleibt oft weg stelle
stehen hallo hallo alter bist du blöd
ich drücke nur weh und dann muss man
irgendwie gehens menü da irgendwie so
was raus als menü auch nicht kann ich
das connect nein kannst du nicht nicht
nicht nein hätte wie wir in das
ausnützen verrichten hier eigentlich
nicht das was ich als kind nie dass eine
kuhhaut bekommen keine ahnung vielleicht
solltest du einfach mal geht auch nicht
doch jetzt geht
aber ich überlebt noch alter und er
drückt nochmal ihr shift und so alles
ganz oft oder schriftlich mit shift
vorwärts geht mal sehen ist die schrift
los es geht
ich bin so gut wie lang lang sagt jemand
der es schwer wir sollten nicht dann ja
komm mit ich habe die mir irgendwann
schon mal gespielt ist dass die mir die
wir mit dem und mit ihr gespielt haben
so und genau das ist die zweite hinter
mir ich habe für drei geboten warum ist
drei nicht dass zwei gewinnt in folge
gewinnt okay gut
ich glaube es verfolgt uns keiner hier
unten ist ein rätsel das weiß ich hier
muss man nämlich voll schöning zu spaßen
wir sollten nur sprinten wenn es auch
wirklich müssen ok beim sprint ass oder
weg von mir ich habe schon ein herz teil
verloren also ich habe schon viel
verloren was die ganze zeit auch nicht
deswegen so gut ich bin da drin hier ist
eine treppe geht nach unten und da unten
setzen rätsel
allerdings weiß ich nicht wie man das
rätsel löst muss ich erst ganz nach oben
kommen
du musst erst ganz nah dran kommen
und warum ist ein knopf als auf dem baum
irgendwie muss man ja du musst da dass
irgendwo ein loch oder glas welches
gefunden naja ich bin ich bin hier gibt
es zehn milliarden
ich höre mich ja es gibt zwei
möglichkeiten wie man das irgendwie
machen kann
party party hier guckt da muss man hier
schalter drücken und irgendwie geht das
dann auf ein preise drücken du ich guck
mal ganz kurz das center ist der blog
wird er ganz kurz comeback angezeigt das
match okay da ist eben wie so gitta und
ganz viel gästen ein mann
wir müssen nur einmal zu muss halt ein
stab einnahmen auf was noch jemand kommt
wache schieben
okay die kaufkraft aufgabe ist jemand
noch die zeit ausmachen
123 49
ich versuche einfach mein android gast
mit speer code macht das ist das haus
vom nikolaus aber es geht nicht ganz
123456 das sind 9 sache nicht viele
möglichkeiten gibt ein stück von jeden
nur einmal drin
richtig viele hat den start eines neuen
ausrufezeichen auf dem taschenrechner
hatte keine ahnung dass woanders hin
dass viel zu klug für uns ich wohl mein
taschenrechner raus was du jetzt damit
oder google oder sowie das offen geht
google vielleicht geht weiter 9
und dann ist ausrufezeichen hinter ich
weiß das gibt das kann gar nicht sein
6 362 hunderttausend millionen drei kam
sein so viele verschiedene unglaublich
viele die das ist ja dann hab ich was
falsch eingeben kannst du auch 29 x 8 x
7 x
kannst du auch teilweise sachen
auslassen oder so das heißt du kannst
einmal nur den dann nur den und den hat
auch stimmt das sind schon immens viele
ja jetzt alle wirklich gesagt hatte
so lange habe ich das auch keine
batterien warum macht man den sohn
rätsel ohne dass es irgendeine
möglichkeit gibt es einfacher zum rüber
was du da jemandem roten umhang und ist
ob der weihnachtsmann
er war ein platz machen kam an nein ich
denke mal fest aber wir leben noch
wir sind unseren top 20 fast schon am 1
ja so war der falsche weg hier warum
kommt man da nicht rein die kugel das
jetzt kann ich erstmal games 2
ich guck mal hier irgendwas erst jetzt
schalte das heißt auf englisch beggar
zudem dafür rätsel heißt es nicht alter
ich weiß dass ich wusste also ich kenne
ich weiß das ja quest vielleicht nein
kreis das aufgabe drittel muss erstmal
hier rauskomme form was man brauchen wir
schon wieder diesen scheiß haltern wo
bist du
am ausgang vorsichtig heraus gerade erst
mal rauskommt dann werden wir dann als
kita abgestempelt sowieso
hallo oder lösemittel portiert der will
man wahrscheinlich spectator oder so
nicht siehst du dir jemand mit dem
hinterausgang
ich bin hinter dir ich weiß dann bald es
irgendwo ein dorf weiter kurz mit la la
la la la maddalena da hinten ist
irgendwo wir können erst mal beim
wasserfall gucken denke nicht dass so
viele gekommen sind bei eine menge ich
schon gestorben sind ich habe jetzt den
chat aus weißt du wie viele noch leben
17 16 16 training stimmt irgendwas
rätseln zu der oben lang
hier ist noch nicht bestimmt nicht
einfach nur schluss kommt dass da
irgendwas abbau nicht mal klänge doch
aber man darf pilze und gras und so
abbauen
ja es ist ja nur mist was als gras hier
so dunkel decken kann nichts erkennen
weder den shader nah bei mir ist alles
dunkel ja dafür was schöneres als die
rückfahrten finde ich nicht schöner
hätte ich meinung in die kommentare was
sie nicht schon nur noch 6 aus und nur
14 städte trips remane jetzt sind wir
ganz am ende
da ist ein boden ich dachte schon hier
oben irgendwo eine komische konstruktion
und glaub ich eine kiste
hallo gestern stimmte ist eine kiste
sehr wichtig dominik eine kiste ist wo
bist du mein fußball kann im riederwald
okay gut was ist hier
wir können witten bochum muss aber sein
ist doch so specials hier kommentiere
keine zeigen wo was als ich weiß nicht
mal wirklich was ist
quatsch hätten ihm die mikro was mir
aufgefallen deswegen bin ich auch so
leise gewesen
ich habe ehrlich
zumindest sei nicht mit einer kiste
eindeutigen gott warum mir das bitte in
eine andere richtung andere richtung
laufen
warum weiß ich nicht aber ich hole mir
brauchst auto verrät aber gleich weil du
keine luft mehr hass blablabla kommentar
andere richtung
ich bin vergifte mich dass er ist erst
mal beim schwimmen ist ein glück und
einfach nie was ich werde da oben war
was hätten in den baum reingemusst
erwarte ich kann dir etwas ist nur die
schalt ist das jetzt nacht wird ich sehe
jetzt hier rechts am rand gleich 18
remane dass man rechts anja bei unserer
auswahl aber direkt verkackt wir kommt
kann man mit am rand finden uns ein
wenig tribut
wir müssen am rand bleiben was wir
müssen hier so auf jeden fall am rand
von der maria do kommen erst mal
willkommen bei ihr 0 ausrüstungen ich
suche gartenweg stadt so aus dem wasser
raus kommen kommst du wieder da bist du
bist voll weit in der mitte für mich
auch wirtschaft darf man scheint ja der
darf alle töten aber wir müssen zusammen
dorf alter da kann das ist somit der
einzige ort wo ich weiß dass der
erträgen
das wäre schön wenn man für sich selber
so den regen und wetterverhältnisse
einstellen könnte nikon darauf sah ich
bin all vitaminreich bruder gefallen auf
servern ist es nämlich immer so ich will
da liegen sachen einfach beobachten auf
deiner schon ist ja weil wenn ich glaube
da kommt jemand mit ausrüstung nicht mal
nämlich alle schon gegenseitig gekeltert
bestimmt jemand richtig viel
auch hier ist das direkt offen du bist
du also habe ich komme ja diesmal nahmen
okay gut kommt bestimmt von rechts links
oben unten oder sogar jemand kommt und
mich kate wahrscheinlich zur feuerwehr
für paranoia heißt alter ist so lang ich
bin jetzt in diesen häusern aber hier
ist nichts drin ganz auf mann im haus
viele wasser ist da drin das ist in
meinem kader der typ hat übrigens die
entscheide macht hat wieder neuen pc
jetzt kann er wieder weiterentwickeln
was er habe ich auch bei facebook lesen
okay war mir noch ein bisschen weitere
kurzum gucken
ich hab auch aber dringend essen ja ich
auch tue ich kann nicht mal mehr
sprinten
ich werde es so nah an spawnen man hier
war bestimmt schon was wenn ihr nützt
nichts drin ist dann verschwenden wir
von dir geht diese alter ein rätsel
dass es irgendeine band von einem typen
der hier irgendwie okay wahrscheinlich
ist es doch irgendwie testen aber ich
glaube das soll nur soll nicht machen
jedoch nicht ab oder so jetzt liegen von
button
ich habe ja noch viel mehr einbauen
sollen an an sachen die man bekommen
kann durch so umgehen scheiße button
bringt nichts
denkst du sieht man dass sich firmen
abbaut und das verbunden
sie wollte nur auf den button drücken
ja ich gehe doch mal ein anderes haus
darunter ist auch nicht auf jeden fall
ja ich denke auch dass das ja eigentlich
schon alles ausgebucht sein sollte war
versuch ist es wert
lassen sie bei gelegenheit ist und dann
gucken ob irgendwas abgreifen können
dehner in der mitte ich hab ne kiste wo
es etwas zu essen
das heißt hier war auf jeden fall noch
niemand dann lass uns noch ein bisschen
weiter hier gucken
hier ist eine lan party am wochenende
bei gc steht hier erst mal hin ahnung
was oft wird 1 nr
aus dem knochen und hier etwas diktieren
höher ist dass ich hab mein lederkappe
cool
woher weiß ich nicht das ist meine vom
dach gefallen neben stimme vom dach
gefallen stimmt aber ich will aber keine
opfer hier vorne ist jetzt schon wieder
die mitte aber ich trau mich da nicht
hin
du darfst du nie auf uns aufmerksam
machen dann kommt die an dann testen sie
uns
dina geht um eine mitte du hast viel
weniger sachen als ich war nah und aber
ich bin fast tot
okay gut ich gerne mitte kommt mit
meinem keller hat wir müssen uns ständig
und gucken eine cola vorne nur 45
sekunden dann wenn wir die mitte sowieso
teleportiert alter oft schneller
miteinander zeichen des match ja aber
beim death match was das letzte mal so
dass die sich alle gegenseitig fertig
gemacht haben und dann fand ich habe die
ganze kisten ausgeraubt - die kisten
holen weil das aber einer mit diamant es
mir egal ich uns mir alles an der so
schnell und ich kann ich mal mehr
sprinten steckten andere falsche stelle
was da los mit dem motto er geht jetzt
dir glaube ich ist eine kiste mit der
liste boden schießen
na ja niemand mehr pfeile
ich habe niemals feile ja ich bin damit
ich bin teleportiert von argo online
ich muss auf mich drauf ihr laster
ineinander ich hab im holz werden sonst
gar nicht warum das hast du musst du
musst arena zurückkehren
das ist so das wetter wollte ich das
buch und kampf ich kann ja mal sagen in
welchen kistner was ist okay ich kann
auch keine kisten zu greifen und
seitlich weg teleportiert euch auch
nicht gerade ganz viele sachen damit den
ganz ganz viel erinnert wo ich bin aus
arena rausgegangen
hast du heute nacht du bist tot ja die
rektorin bestimmt ist ja ganz klug und
lauf raus und dann bin ich tot gewesen
so ein blitz an super war ich tot ist
auch vom klavierhocker geflogen ja das
spiel super 6 sind aus das waren dann
die hangar case ist das spiel 1 2
zusammen mit dem akon crafter lebte sei
es für den amc ach ja fest das beste
spiel eigentlich irgendwie noch
irgendwie im team viel mehr spaß
ganz geiler als ich finde dieser war
sehr geil
ja das stimmt ist das ist es lief
einfach die ip ist eu dann irgendeine
zahl in die 26 punkte csg punkt in wehr
heißt die internetseite wo man das alles
sieht behandlung
das ist ja viel interessanter natürlich
wurde das keine ahnung habe ich dennoch
einschreibung sagen meine lieben freunde
sehen wir uns beim nächsten video chat